[Music]
man whoa look at that new guy who's that
that's my cue I gotta go
what's gonna fight with Captain America
I stole his shield up threw it at him
he's big he throws amazing things ever
happen to mrs. Oakes like a ruse and I
just sort of slipped in hey Jesus second
coming hey Nathan Walsall the rich and
the powerful I don't care about us we're
to pick up after with their table scraps
these alien bastards are tough you got
to use the stuff they use the world's
change time we change two ways Linux
retreat next mission will call you keep
it a little more mentoring if your real
assets into you that's not a hug and
just grab the door for you oh all right
kid good luck out there someone is
collecting stuff from Avengers battles
I'm building these crazy weapons this is
my chance to prove myself
what if somebody had died tonight
different story right cuz that's on you
I wanted you to be better eight years
without any trouble from those bozos up
in stark tower and it's no faster than
red tights shows oh he thinks he can
tear down everything I'd go full up
around New Avengers weaponry to load up
we're gonna put them out of business
we're gonna take everything they got
[Music]
get a sake
[Music]
do you know him - yeah still issue
[Music]